right now president trump is continuing
to say there is widespread voter fraud
here in the state of nevada
but his campaign and state republicans
have yet to show more than several
isolated cases now one of those cases
involve a woman who died in 2017.
the i-team's david charns looking into
that and david you talked to this
woman's husband kirk cartel's wife rose
marie who
passed away three years ago she is one
of two cases of somebody who died on
clark county's voter rolls
they were sent a mail-in ballot and that
ballot was returned the question
now is though who voted for her
it was disbelief
just it made no sense to me kirk cartel
said he was surprised when he found out
his wife
who died in 2017 had sent in a mail-in
ballot
i was surprised because she passed away
three years ago i was surprised to even
get that
rosemary hartl died at 52 from breast
cancer
her name is still on clark county's
voter rolls and since
everyone in those roles got a ballot one
was sent to rose marie
but kirk says a ballot never got to his
house
that is pretty sickening to me to be
honest with you according to ballot
tracks the mail-in ballot was sent
october
9 and returned the day before election
day clark county officials say
rose marie's signature is a match to
what's on their records
registrar for elections joe gloria says
any illegal activity will be flagged
now keith hartle wonders who took
advantage of his grief
adding he's surprised his wife received
a ballot at all
it certainly brings up a lot of
discomfort
you know there's a pretty exhaustive
process you go through when someone
passes
and in a second case a man who died in
2017 also had a ballot cast in his name
but
election officials tell me it appears
his daughter actually sent
in that ballot and she never cast her
own ballot clark county has forwarded
these two cases up to the secretary of
state's office they're the ones who
actually investigate
i'm david charns 8 news now